[Musique]
Léon Monet est un collectionneur et
premier soutien des impressionnistes
dans leur début à leur même qu'ils ne
sont pas encore reconnus comme
impressionnistes il avait 20 œuvres de
son frère dans sa collection et des
chefs il avait également des oeuvres de
Pissarro Renoir sisle qui était des amis
très proches de Claude Monet il va donc
les soutenir à leur tout début non
seulement en achetant leurs heures mais
également en présentant leurs œuvres
dans les expositions de Rouen et
également en faisant visiter sa
collection à ses amis à Rouen
[Musique]
le portrait de Léon Monet peint par
Claude en 1874 est une œuvre totalement
inédite présentée pour la première fois
au public un portrait qui n'a pas été
accepté par Léon Monet et qu'il a caché
pourquoi ce refus la réponse pourrait se
trouver dans le fait que il y a
peut-être cette facture très libre ces
touches très visibles notamment sur le
front dans le cou cette oeuvre que l'on
voit presque en train de se faire
[Musique]
ce qui est très intéressant c'est le
rapport des deux frères à la couleur on
a d'un côté Léon Monet qui a
commercialisé ces nouvelles couleurs
synthétiques et de l'autre Claude qui a
travaillé avec ses nouvelles couleurs
qui bien sûr était aussi diffusée sur le
marché des couleurs on ne peut dire avec
certitude que Claude Monet a employé les
couleurs que son frère Léon
commercialisés mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il a travaillé avec ses
couleurs synthétiques qui ont été créées
au 19e siècle
[Musique]
monnaie et ses amis
impressionnistes sont modernes par leur
sujet sont modernes par la facture et
sont aussi modernes par les couleurs
qu'ils emploient dans leur palette
[Musique]